now read with me CIN says number one
find the area I've heard there's nothing
precious to do find the area of each
shaded region Beloit by evaluating the
appropriate integral now let's just look
at the pieces yet just look at that
sentence okay I'll try to find an area
the way that I do that is by evaluating
you know finding out what's the things
equal to in terms of how big it is the
appropriate intervals so I'm gonna write
one of these things that matches the
area that I'm after let's have a look at
the first one it's a nice simple one in
fact is very similar to the UM the speed
distance time exam I just gave what is
this and I think that's okay so what are
the pieces that I need have a look at
this thing carefully okay there are only
really three things you need to put into
here right Anthony where you start and
finish your area and F is whatever your
function looks like okay in our case I'm
going to ex-ante yax you don't need to
muck around with that because what did
that signify what was the DX there's the
width of all there's tiny two rectangles
okay and so I just I just leave it there
okay because it's the same so what
injury would I want to make this the
area is going to be equal to two
here's my guess right now where does it
start it starts the origin right so I go
this is the way I will read it out as
well the integral from 0 to 2 of this
function
2x okay now one of the Haiti things that
we've gotten from when we learn the
differentiation is that this can be used
not just as a thing that you multiply
divide by mine but as an operator you're
you're doing this on something okay and
what this means is differentiate with
respect to whatever that is okay so if I
changed it you know when we're looking
at those rates of change of that short
example okay you know I might say with
respect your time okay all with respect
to the radius or whatever you like okay
so being it that's how it works with
differentiation it's the same language
when we talk about integration right so
this is this area is equal to the
integral from 0 to 2 of 2x with respect
to X okay
now by the way just like with Sigma
notation can you see that that X doesn't
matter right I could have changed this
tip aunty's if I wanted to okay or I
could have changed it to use that's
another one or I could have changed it
to change its remember we caught in the
Sigma notation it gets a dummy variable
right it's just sitting there that's why
I can put numbers ooh okay I'll go back
to X so how do I write this well I'm
gonna have the primitive function where
this came from
right now you notice this is important
I'm gonna get to this plus C in a second
I'm gonna ignore it for a minute and you
can tell me why I mean you're just
standing far
they want now I want to evaluate this at
the end and at the beginning and
subtract okay now we have a shorthand
way of writing that which is with these
square brackets okay now what that
stands for is evaluated it to you your
up and down evaluated at zero your lower
bound and take the difference that's it
now why didn't I put the constant in
right this is this constant which I said
this you know when I work out the
primitive I don't know which one you
know I might have an x squared plus 1 or
minus 2 or something like that well
let's just suppose it was possible let's
just suppose because it could it be
right here into what difference would it
make
well let's evaluate it evaluate that at
2 okay now evaluate it at 0 what happens
that's 5 minus 1 that's you can see
anything I like okay it's always going
to cancel silence okay because of what's
happening here I've evaluated constant
and then I'm subtracting the same
constant in very next moment okay so
that's why whatever constant is 0 okay